what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us
trying to get our lunch money right i
don't know what plane is doing who cares
i've had a lot of coffee so i'm ready to
rock and roll
don't forget that block five is now the
sponsor of lunch money that means that
you can go to blockfy.com very simple
if you have very smart brains you go to
blockfy.com
you sign up for an account you deposit
value into it and then you can
earn up to eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can buy and sell crypto currencies on
their crypto exchange
or you can leave crypto there and take a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can sign up for the waitlist for
their bitcoin rewards credit card
again but you have to have big big brain
stuff here go to blockfy.com
to be able to do all that stuff let's
get into it
oh i was like what is behind my head but
that's just on the camera
okay um so coin i want you to think
coinbase made a rousing debut on wall
street wednesday with shares of the
digital currency
exchange rising as high as 429 dollars
briefly giving it a market value over a
hundred
billion my partner is not paying
attention and he will get in trouble
soon what do you believe
what do you believe is about here i
believe that that's great for
coinbase that's very interesting only
the market will tell
let's see how it performs now that it's
a public company and accountable to
public shareholders they have to be more
transparent he has
brian armstrong has to be more yes he
does
yes he do yes he do listen coinbase
isn't even 100 billion dollar company
traded up over 100 but it settled it
ended up being an 88 billion
market cap company uh but i think it is
actually undervalued there we'll see
if you're telling me that they're gonna
do on an annualized basis eight billion
dollars in revenue
and it's only trading at about eight or
i'm sorry 10 to 11 times annualized
revenue
uh news flash have you seen the market
they should be trading like 25 times
according to everyone else's uh
multiples so
we'll see what happens but i think that
yesterday actually
uh was a little bit um confusing uh
it's not what i think a lot of people
expected but what that does mean is that
the direct listing process
actually probably worked usually what
you see is with an ipo they go and they
price the ipo and there's this massive
pop what that usually means is that and
you want the pop as a
no well no if you're the company you do
not want the pop because
it looks good it means that you left a
lot of money on the table i know that
but the investors who are buying the ipo
of course
and so i think that what we're going to
end up seeing here is that more and more
companies are going to realize that a
direct listing is a better mechanism to
actually go public
and therefore there will be more
choosing this path direct list things
were kind of
all the hype in 2019 and then people
were like oh was this going to work i
think spotify was the first to do it
people like oh is this going to work and
then we've seen more and more companies
do it slack did it who else did it
baby yeah um did it i don't remember
what airbnb yeah
but anyway so it's showing that it's
gaining traction and now it's not as
exotic as it seemed
two years ago next black
rock ceo larry fink is saying
that a host of factors are likely to
propel markets higher in the near term
even as the s p 500 and the dow hover
near
record level levels he said i believe
because of monetary stimulus fiscal
stimulus the cash on the sidelines the
earnings
the markets are okay markets are going
to continue to be stronger he has
he is very bullish on the stock market i
wrote about larry fink this morning in
the
newsletter but i'm not going to talk
about the same thing because that was
on this crypto comments this is speaking
about his stock market comments
i think that larry is incredibly smart
they built an amazing business at
blackrock
i tend to agree with him on being
bullish about the stock market but it's
less about those companies are going to
do some amazing thing that's going to 2
or 3x the value of them
and it's much much more about the fact
that we simply are going to continue to
see
intervention in markets by governments
and central banks
they're going to continue to manipulate
interest rates down i saw recently that
uh people are estimating that the
federal reserve's not going to raise
rates until 2024
which is nuts and we're also going to
continue to see more and more stimulus
monetary and fiscal policy
uh manipulating these markets and so in
a world where
literally trillion dollars is no longer
a big number
you're just going to see liquidity
sloshing around and things like the
stock market
as an asset class are going to do very
very well and then people holding cash
are gonna get punished and so being
bullish on stocks right now i think is
actually a pretty smart
uh way to look at it again there's
concerns around inflation and many other
uh kind of negative side effects but if
you look at it just from a macro market
structure
uh there's a very good chance the stock
market continues for quite a while
because they are just going to
manipulate it that way
charles schwab added a record 3.2
million new clients in the first quarter
of 2021
more new accounts than all of 2020.
schwab said it now operates nearly 32
million brokerage accounts and has about
7.07 trillion in client assets
the ceo said elevated interest in
technology and other growth-oriented
stocks
as well as heightened market attention
to certain names via social media
significantly bolstered trading activity
how much of this
is because of gamestop well
it's probably not game stop as much as
just overall people were sitting at home
and they were trying to figure out what
to do there was no sports on
right now it was 20. this is the first
quarter of 2021
yeah but what ends up happening is
because asset prices are
rising so quickly uh more and more
people keep coming in to uh into the
market
the other thing you have to remember too
is they just spent nine months sitting
at home saving a lot of money
so how many people got rid of their
apartment and like moved back home we
know tons of people who did that
how many people moved out of new york
city to a lower cost
place how many people left san francisco
in
uh how many people used to commute and
now actually have that cash they don't
need
how many people used to go out every
night and spend money at restaurants and
now they weren't right so there's just
a lot more personal savings rate and
personal income
all went up and the government was
handing out money like it was candy so
they have that money as well
and so when you have all that cash
sitting there i think people naturally
say well what do i do with it
there's only so much you can consume and
so naturally people say well maybe i
should be investing some of this maybe i
should
be putting in a retirement account
paying off my debt buying stocks
and that's where i think you're seeing
more and more interest in a lot of these
assets what's interesting is coinbase
did more
revenue in q1 than all of 2020.
uh charles schwab signed up more
customers in q1
than all of 2020 so it may not be so
much kind of a vertical
or a secular trend as much as just
overall financial markets are seeing an
absolute boom in business
walmart is investing in cruz the
self-driving uh
company that's majority owned by gm it's
part of a new 2.75 billion dollar
funding round for the company
the decision to invest comes about five
months after the company started working
on a pilot program to use cruise
self-driving vehicles
to for deliveries in scottsdale arizona
cruz is now valued at two billion
dollars
wow what sorry 2.75 billion
what so walmart no what no it is
yup no 2.75 billion going into the
company
shoot so then it's not valued at 2
billion just for the record
i said no she said that she was right
she was wrong no the article was wrong
how do you how do you say because it
they mean in january it was valued at 2
billion but it can't be valued at 2
billion still
no the investment round size what is now
2.75 it was 2 billion in the beginning
of the company this is why we're a great
team see together we'll find the truth
the truth can't hide from us together
we'll find out this is
written in a misleading manner um it
kind of is actually
why is walmart but i was still right
why is walmart interested in
self-driving vehicles
will they use it for anything but
deliveries
uh well they're probably gonna use it
for a lot of different stuff so
deliveries
is kind of the uh from walmart directly
to the customer but imagine all of the
supply
chain logistics how many times do you
drive one time we were driving
uh along the east coast and we started
counting how many
amazon trucks we passed walmart's the
same thing right and so these big 18
wheelers
you can get all sorts of autonomous
driving there now suddenly you can go 24
7
you don't need to be paying people all
that kind of stuff cruz's valuation
is 30 billion it is not two i told you
okay go up go on i don't think she said
that i want to rewind the tape no
problem
uh but i think that on top of that
you're going to see autonomous
vehicles go from everything from the
18-wheelers
to eventually you're going to see it all
the way down to like robots in the
actual warehouses etc right and so
what you're going to continue to see is
um these large
companies these large retailers pursue
technology to get
more automation more efficiency and more
accuracy as well
like one of the things that's kind of an
underrated feature is if you really
think about it
when's the last time you ordered
something from an amazon or a walmart
and you got the wrong thing like you
used that used to happen like actually
pretty often happen often now that
doesn't really happen that often it
still happens every once in a while but
for the most part like when you order
something
you get what you ordered and there's
technology behind that there's logistics
behind that like there's a bunch of
things that they've been improving over
time
so if you zoom out you look over the
last 20 years the accuracy of these
services has drastically improved
the time to delivery has drastically
improved and also their unit economics
have been improved so they're able to
deliver this stuff
at a cheaper cost because their ends
still make the same or more money
on it that's just all technology and so
i think that they're going to continue
to pursue technology to see how can they
take that idea and put it on steroids
you're very good at analysis
yeah of course well that's what i do for
a living so go ahead actually what i do
for a living is i screw around on the
internet but this that's happening
guys wait let me just complain to them
i've been locked out of my twitter
account for three days
nobody on twitter is helping me zero
people are helping me i can't get back
in
apparently it was compromised it would i
don't know how i don't know why but now
i can't get into my own account
so that is why i have not been tweeting
i've been living out in the real world
non-virtual world okay your buddy jim
cramer
is saying that he used bitcoin he ca
he sold bitcoin which he calls phony
money
to pay for real money and he paid off
his home
yeah jim i love you man come on
first rule of bitcoin no he said not i
now own a house
lock stock and barrel because i bought
this currency
can we say is it possible for me to say
that i bought jim cramer a house
[Laughter]
he he used the profits from his
investment in bitcoin
so what do we think about wow my face is
shiny as hell today
so what do we think about jim buying
or selling selling bitcoin to purchase a
home
whereas you wouldn't even consider
purchasing a couch
no listen
jim he had the courage and conviction he
bought
when i told him when it was 12 000. it
is now
64. 64 000. i think that he's going to
regret doing this
but you know what he owns a house man he
owns a house the man owns a freaking
house
that's what he wants to do if he's happy
i'm happy for him congratulations jim
i'm glad that it worked out for you just
don't sell the rest who knows who knows
how much he bought who knows how much he
sold
well i i actually know exactly okay
don't tell us or if you want to tell
someone no go ahead okay
um it's ask lunch money jimmy chill
that's my favorite jimmy chill
ask lm in the comments below uh from
vaibhav he says uh when do you think btc
bull run can end when do you think
never i haven't i have i have
a saying that says it's gonna go up
don't worry yeah she does stumble on
sometimes you know when it drops like
three percent i'm like
no just kidding um the bull run
it's going to continue exactly how it
always happens supply shock
repricing of the asset gets overheated
corrects
supply shock repricing gets overheated
corrects supply shock general direction
is probably
if you zoom out it's all about what
what's your time frame so if you've got
a long
uh time horizon then uh you know it's
headed in the same direction but
if you want to buy a house buy the house
moist day 97 of commenting i waited
until just before bedtime to comment to
see if i got if i'd get an email
alas tomorrow could be the day i'm
getting a tire change tomorrow wish i
could have known about uh
pomp boys motors before i made the
appointment lol hashtag moyesgang
built different what do you want to say
people are commenting saying
anthony be a man of your word email
moist what is going on for the record
this hasn't been 90 days
for the record okay even though moyes is
saying day 97
we said i know all right i'm going to
send the email
moist to be honest i was at dinner last
night and i thought to myself i should
email moist
and then i went and i didn't have your
email on hand
tick tock stars josh richards and
griffin johnson
and my friend michael gruen oh and
michael ruin and
uh who else is there uh roberts
yeah a lot a lot of great people had a
lot of fun a lot of fun i learned a lot
lots of fun
i had a lot of fun it was the most fun
it was so much fun i don't
ever need to have fun ever again all
right that's it for today guys have a
great
thursday thursday bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block five than
you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends